ice tour d'une forteresse du vin il
montre à tout le monde qu s'est posé le
geste est peut-être mal assurée mais la
volonté d'acier six ans après un
terrible accident de voiture
romain n'est pas debout il est au sommet
on avait dit de moi que je prends ma
plume de jean mas jamais je reparle
jamais parlé beaucoup beaucoup trop pour
venir en béton achetons boîte dct venant
juste territoriaux pour les hommes la
société n'importe quand
je m'appelle lucas jouanno je suis
embauché dans l'entreprise de romain
depuis mardi dernier jeu malvoyants d'un
oeil et je suis handicapé d'une main je
conseille pas pouvoir repartir dans le
métier j'avais un problème c'est que les
gens ils pensent travailleurs handicapés
penser infirmant on tourne en masse ils
ont produit purement politique des
rythmes ans ça marche je m'appelle m
rickman bergie j'ai 30 ans moi ce qui me
plaît ici c'est que l'entreprise s'est
pas patron nous aussi on est une famille
nous qu'on est tous unis 1 1 qu'un
problème on arrête tout on va l'aider on
discute on trouve des solutions mais une
bonne ambiance
ce monsieur guillaume stepan sucette
d'équipement fait
c'est dur c'est physique c'est crevant
say we you to et voulait mais quand même
cette entreprise oui parce que ben j'ai
pu en voir mon appartement ma pays
donc après bas par la suite peut-être un
véhicule donc on le souhaite
six mois le revenu normal est-ce que tu
en as besoin de londres
c'est pour dijon paris pub je tiens
j'vais ce rêve ne serait viable
aujourd'hui wyss locaux où ils seront
remplis de dans le vie que peu de gens
qui ont vraiment besoin
on me dira bas en grande pompe devant
non ceux morts j'ai eu beau jeu
seulement battu pour la vie
d'aujourd'hui et regroupe un énorme
intérêt des nageurs de question pour moi
de bonnes données créée à la force du
poignet tout le monde en bois ne l'a
jamais bénéficié d'aucune subvention
alors le prochain défi sera de décrocher
l'agrément entreprises adaptées en
attendant chacun peut aider et faire un
don